hey 42 here there are a hundred and
sixty-eight different currencies in the
world and billions of dollars worth of
new banknotes are printed every day
globally here's some of the most amazing
facts about money before coins were
invented in 1500 BC people used to trade
in all kinds of strange commodities such
as gold rice fish Bali salt tea leaves
cows blood and even bat guano in America
the word book to mean money comes from
the days when people used to trade
various animal skins including books
skins as currency the art of producing
money is precise and complex each coin
has to be exactly the same as the next
so that people accept that they are
worth the same amount of money
traditionally coins were made by either
striking metal between two engraved dyes
or by casting them in moles however in
the 18th century coins were made by new
steam-powered machinery which greatly
increased the number of coins that could
be produced in a day the production of
banknotes however is a bit more
complicated originally banknotes were
black and white but now almost all of
them are brightly coloured and feature
highly complex designs which makes them
harder to counterfeit but also instantly
recognizable as a national currency in
1923 hyperinflation caused German
currency to lose almost all of its value
it became so worthless that people gave
it to children to play with or even used
it as wallpaper India has a banknote of
zero value they look exactly the same as
of a banknote but are worth exactly zero
Pease you might ask what's the point
well corruption in India is widespread
and the major concern made government
officials in India require monetary
bribes for all sorts of permits and
services the zero rupee banknotes serves
an important purpose it is given to
officials who request bribes as a
statement of peaceful non-cooperation
each zero rupee note bears a declaration
that states I promise to neither accept
nor give a bribe its sole purpose is to
make a statement ironically this makes
the zero rupee banknotes both valuable
and worth absolutely nothing at the same
time in most countries and currencies 1
pence pieces cost more money to make
than they are actually worth the US
Treasury spends 2.41 cells to mint each
penny making a huge loss because of this
to Canadian government stopped producing
pennies altogether
in 2013 the world's largest
counterfeiter of US currency is North
Korea they produce high-quality fakes
that the American Secret Service has
nicknamed super dollars because they so
closely resemble genuine notes the
production of banknotes requires 0 trees
no paper is used at all all paper
currency is made from a custom blend of
cotton and linen usually around 25%
cotton and 75% linen 90% of US bank
notes contain traces of cocaine queen
elizabeth ii is the queen of currency
her portrait has graced the currencies
of 33 different countries more than any
other individual in head
stewey Canada was the first country to
use the British monarchs portrait on
their banknotes in 1935 when it printers
the at the time
nine-year-old princess on its twenty
dollar notes more monopoly money is
printed every year than real money if
you have just $10 in your pocket and no
debts you are wealthier than 25% of
Americans a check is only an instruction
to a bank it's therefore can be written
on absolutely anything and as long as it
has all the necessary components it will
be honored by the bank cheques have been
written on doors stone slabs bananas and
even cows banknotes are pretty gross a
study showed that 14% of banknotes
contain fecal matter and 94% contain
pathogens viruses and bacteria can live
on most surfaces for about 48 hours but
they can live on paper money for up to
14 days
Icelanders pay for things using credit
and debit cards more than any other
country in the world 70% of all business
in Iceland is done with plastic compared
to 39% in North America Australia makes
his banknotes from polymer which is a
type of synthetic plastic they last for
2.5 times longer than traditional cotton
and linen banknotes and are surprisingly
more eco-friendly they are also harder
to counterfeit the UK will also be
switching to plastic banknotes in 2016
some coins have grooved ridges around
their edges they serve little purpose
today but they were originally added in
the days when coins were made from
precious metals such as silver and gold
people used to scrape the edges of the
coins before spending them
then sell the precious metals they
scraped off the grooved ridges were
added to stop people doing this a vast
majority of the money in the world is
not physical money
it is simply numbers in the computers of
banks money which cannot be backed by a
physical commodity such as gold is
called fiat money fiat money includes
digital funds paper banknotes and coins
these kinds of money are only valuable
simply because a government declares it
as an official currency however over non
government backed fiat money can become
valuable just because there's a high
demand for it such as the emerging
Bitcoin currency which has no
centralized control body the only thing
that makes Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies valuable is the simple
fact that lots of people desire it and
want it unfine aliy if all the gold in
the world were melted down into a single
square block it would only be 21 meters
on each side thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2
you